we decided we'd come up this evening and  I also came up on Thursday with my mum  so you've been twice I bet this will be  my the second time yeah my goodness I  didn't think the feet would cope to be  fair but um yeah Thursday my mum gave up  after six hours it was just a bit too  much it's much colder and the queues  have moved a little bit better this time  around and so my husband wanted to come  so I said okay I'll do I'll come with  but my feet my feet are struggling now I  bet so did you manage to get in the last  time yes yeah and what was it like oh  incredible just absolutely incredible  and and obviously I've come back and  said to my husband about how amazing it  was and which is obviously he then felt  he'd missed out so hence we're here so  it's a little you could this time  um this will I think it'll be about 12  hours by the time we get through so last  time 13 and a half  goodness me that's loyalty it is